(gentle music)
- The protection of water
resources and the provision
of high quality drinking
water is a key priority
for public health.
The Federal Safe Drinking
Water Act protects the public
from legacy, well-known contaminants.
However, there are certain
chemicals, which we call
emerging contaminants,
that might be present
in our drinking water.
Emerging contaminants
represent a special challenge
because the very limited
availability of information
regarding them, and most importantly,
they're not regulated by federal or state.
1.4 dioxane is a stabilizer
that has been used
with many organic solvents
that it is difficult
to be filtered from the drinking water.
So whatever there was a
chemical spill of solvents,
the 1.4 dioxane was with them
and it has been detected
in several Superfund sites
throughout United States
and internationally.
Superfund sites are areas
that there is a contamination,
a chemical spill or environmental
release of chemicals
by the chemical industry.
We decided to develop a research
center primarily focusing
on this chemical.
The Yale Superfund Research
Center aims to study the role
of 1.4 dioxane in human health,
as well as better methods
of detecting it in the
environment and also better ways
of mitigating that from
the drinking water.
Based on studies, 1.4 dioxane
is a probable human carcinogen.
Therefore, we are aiming to
study the molecular mechanism
by which 1.4 dioxane, along
or with its co-contaminants
may cause cancer and at the
same time, we are aiming
to develop biomarkers of
exposure to these chemicals.
Since there is no epidemiological studies
confirming the carcinogenicity
of this compound in humans.
Dr. Deziel and her
colleagues are investigating
the exposure assessment of 1.4
dioxane in human populations.
- Project two is an
exposure assessment study,
which is the study of how
people come into contact
with chemicals as they move
through their everyday lives.
This could be pollutants in
the air that they breathe,
chemicals in the food they're eating,
the personal care products they're using,
or even contaminants in
their drinking water.
It's really important to
understand what people
are exposed to, 'cause we
have to know who is exposed
to what amounts.
You know, certain populations
may have higher levels
of these chemicals in their drinking water
or in their blood, and that
will help us understand
whether or not they're at
risk for any health problems.
Our study area includes two
counties on Long Island,
Nassau and Suffolk Counties,
and these two counties are home
to dozens of state and
federal Superfund sites.
We're going to hundreds
of homes on Long Island
to interview people about
the consumer products
they're using, collect
their drinking water
and test it for chemicals,
collect blood samples to look
for health markers, and
map where people live
in relation to hazardous waste sites.
Another reason why exposure
assessment is so important
is because by identifying communities
with higher levels of exposures,
that can help direct some
of the interventions.
So, some of the other projects
in this Superfund Center
are developing treatment
devices that could be deployed
in homes that have particularly
high levels of 1.4 dioxane
or other chemicals in
their drinking water.
- 1.4 dioxane is a very
difficult pollutant
to treat if it is in
groundwater because it's so tiny
and it loves water, it doesn't
like to stick to the surface.
So, because of that property,
the conventional method
to treat pollutants does not
work well for 1.4 dioxane.
We are trying to use electricity
and electric power is going
to produce oxidation power,
meaning destruction power.
Destruction of 1.4
dioxane by hydroxy radical
is a proven chemistry but
it is extremely difficult
to realize in a smaller scale setting.
For in this center what
you are trying to do
is to make a small modular system.
For user's point of
view, you just plug in,
connect the pipe, and
it destroys 1.4 dioxane.
That's the goal, and we
are at the initial stage
of realizing that goal.
- So one critically important
aspect of the Superfund Center
is the community engagement core
and I'm leading that along
with Adrienne Esposito
who is the Executive
Director of Citizens Campaign
For the Environment, which
is a large grassroots
organization based in Long Island
that has a long history of working
on drinking water quality
issues in the study area.
It's a very rich partnership
between the university and the community.
And the community is
directly providing input
into the science.
So as scientists, we're not
just going into communities
and studying what we think is important
we're asking the people who live there
what they're concerned about,
and their, their concerns
and ideas are directly
informing our research questions
and our science.
Doing the science is incredibly important,
but once the work is done
and the results are in
it's really important
to format the results
and information in a way that's useful
to the community and to policy makers.
- It is very important
that we inform stakeholders
and legislators regarding toxic limits
of those emerging contaminants
in our drinking water.
So eventually we would
like to inform policy
on setting up standards
for our drinking water.